khi lắm này, tâm điểm gì nhên là lời trận quối cùng của gia đợt một phòng bản.
Đấu chiều người dành vào mùa đồng hàng yên không chung hàng đi âm.
Và không cuộc sự ký vọng của hôm một, tập đầu siêu kinh điện,
để hạ mà gia đợt một, giữa sai còn phần sop,
cùng FT Plus đã mang đến những sự biến cực kỳ hạm giản.
Ngay tường khấu cầm chọn FT Plus, tuần gia đổi hình mạnh nhất,
những bất ngờ khi hiểu điều gì không có mặt trong đội lý xưa pháp.
Sẽ đầu diễn ra các khẳng ngay từ đi phút đầu.
Tên giống xa làm gần marries,
sẽ còn phát trường vâng lên giả trung của không sau văn bà miếp phút thí đồng khách trọng.
Sà văn hai, tuần FT cũng có hộ bắt đầu,
những FT phòng vụ vực trẻ và suất sắp lửa hả một đều.
Một sang bản bà, FT Plus,
FT Plus, không cho bây giờ bên về FT có khổ thị hiện và nhìn trong lương tỷ số linh hai một truy sau mùi phút thí đấu.
Hí FT cũng mính bản lính thí trở lại để quyết đón,
đánh bà FT Plus, trong xong trình tổ,
tình bằng hai đều và kéo sợ đồng vào và năm quy định.
Ở văn đều khuối, các hai đồ trước tên kéo từng phút,
và khối cùng, phân sự tỉnh tạo trong những phát sử linh thay trọng,
FT Plus, chắc dành trình thắng chung của mà hai,
khách hại dành một măng một cuộc sợ đổi tìm số ý thường.